en el último vídeo hablamos de campos
vectoriales en un contexto de dos
dimensiones y aquí quiero hacer lo mismo
pero para tres dimensiones así que
tenemos un campo vectorial de tres
dimensiones dado por una función digamos
multi variable que tiene una entrada
tridimensional dado por las coordenadas
x jay-z y tenemos un vector de salida
verdad que también va a ser
tridimensional que tiene expresiones de
alguna forma dependientes en x jay-z y
simplemente voy a poner unos puntos por
aquí ahora verdad y la forma en la que
esto funciona digamos justo como en el
caso bidimensional es que vamos a elegir
una muestra de varios puntos en este
espacio de tres dimensiones y para cada
uno de esos puntos consideraremos cuál
es la la salida de esta función y eso
será digamos algún vector tridimensional
y lo dibujamos justo anclado a ese punto
verdad así que para empezar digamos
tomemos un ejemplo muy simple uno donde
el vector de salida es justamente una
constante constante así que en este caso
vamos a hacer que este vector constante
digamos va a ser uno
0 y este vector simplemente tiene una
longitud unitaria en la dirección x
verdad aquí está el eje x y todos los
vectores van a verse digamos algo
parecido cuando tenemos un vector que
tiene una longitud 1 en la dirección xy
lo que hacemos es que en cada punto
posible bueno quizás no no todo punto
posible verdad pero en una muestra
grande de un digamos muchos puntos vemos
que el campo vectorial se ve justamente
así y en cualquier punto del espacio
tenemos digamos estos vectores azules
que son pequeñitos y todos ellos son
digamos copias idénticas de digamos del
mismo vector verdad cada uno apunta en
una digamos unidad de longitud en la
dirección x así que mientras el campo
vectorial digamos en principio se ve
bastante aburrido de verdad pero
podríamos hacerlo un poquito más
divertido si cambiamos nuestra salida
digamos que depende de alguna forma en
el punto en el que estemos digamos
parados digamos en el punto de entrada
así que lo que vamos a hacer es que la
salida depende
una forma en el punto de entrada así que
lo que vamos a hacer es simplemente
cambiar el campo vectorial porque 0 0
así que esto seguirá moviéndose en la
dirección x pero ahora va a depender del
valor y así que pensemos un segundo
antes de que cambiemos la imagen qué es
lo que significa esto
bueno el eje y es este que se encuentra
aquí y ahora el eje z digamos es el que
está apuntando hacia nuestra cara así
que a medida que aumentamos el valor de
ya digamos 123 la longitud de estos
vectores va a incrementar y eso digamos
pensaremos que va a ser un vector más
fuerte en la dirección x verdad un
vector quizás muy fuerte en la dirección
x si estamos muy arriba y si es negativa
entonces estos vectores van a apuntar en
la dirección contraria así que vamos a
ver cómo se vería esto y aquí lo tenemos
en este campo vectorial digamos el color
y la longitud se usan para indicar la
magnitud del vector así que los vectores
rojos son muy largos los vectores azules
son muy pequeños verdad y en cero pues
en realidad no vemos nada
verdad porque esos vectores tienen una
longitud cero y justo como en el caso de
dos dimensiones cuando dibuja vamos los
campos vectoriales
en realidad mentíamos un poquito verdad
esto está en realidad debería tener una
longitud de 1 verdad y cuando cuando ya
es igual a 1 esto debería tener una
longitud unitaria aquí donde ya 5 o 6 en
realidad debería ser un vector muy largo
pero estamos mintiendo un poquito porque
si si dibujáramos todos estos vectores a
su escala real en realidad se vería muy
amontonada la imagen así que un par de
cosas que podemos notar en este ejemplo
es que aunque la salida depende en
realidad no depende de la variable equis
o zeta si nos movemos en la dirección x
en realidad no cambian y si nos movemos
en la dirección zeta que es hacia arriba
y abajo en realidad también los vectores
no cambian verdad solo cambian cuando
nos movemos en la dirección así que
bueno estamos empezando a tener cierta
intuición de cómo es que la salida puede
depender de la entrada y ahora vamos a
hacer algo un poquito diferente digamos
que ahora nuestra salida depende
nuestra entrada y de nuestras tres
componentes de la entrada que son xy set
así que vamos a considerar simplemente
la función identidad es decir en cada
punto x jay-z el vector de salida será
el mismo x y z
así que pensemos que es lo que significa
digamos este campo vectorial o cómo se
vería así que tenemos un punto dado
digamos un punto flotando en el espacio
y pensamos cuál es el vector de salida
para esto bueno el punto tiene cierta
componente x cierta componente y una
componente zeta
y ese vector le corresponde el vector x
y z verdad que será digamos uno que
apunta desde el origen hacia el punto
mismo verdad y ahora vamos a dibujar
este aquí del origen al punto y debido a
digamos como consideramos los campos
vectoriales este vector lo movemos de
tal suerte que en vez de estar anclado
al origen ahora estará anclado al mismo
punto verdad y quizás lo que más debemos
rescatar de este ejemplo es que este
este vector va a apuntar justamente a en
dirección opuesta al origen verdad hacia
fuera
origen y digamos que mientras más lejos
se encuentra el punto de anclaje más
largo será de este vector así que con
esto vamos a fijarnos en el campo
vectorial muy bien aquí lo tenemos
nuevamente estamos mintiendo un poco
cuando dibujamos estos vectores verdad
estos vectores rojos que están muy
alejados deberían ser realmente largos
porque este vector debería tener la
misma longitud que digamos la distancia
del punto al origen pero digamos para
que se vea claro y limpio el campo
vectorial simplemente estamos rescatando
todo y notamos que los vectores azules
que están digamos más cerca del centro
en realidad son muy muy muy pequeños
verdad y estos en realidad también están
apuntando digamos hacia fuera del origen
y este es uno de esos campos vectoriales
que en realidad es muy bonito verdad un
muy buen ejemplo que nos da bastante
intuición de cómo se pintan también los
campos vectoriales en tres dimensiones
verdad y ahora al menos tenemos una idea
de cómo pensar a la función identidad
como un campo vectorial en el próximo
vídeo vamos a
ver otro ejemplo que es quizás un
poquito más complicado que éste y espero
que podamos tener una mejor intuición de
cómo es que las salidas pueden depender
de las tres variables x y y ceta